here's a question we tolerate certain
behavior on a girl's period right as men
like a girl's on her period and she's
she's grumpy she's angry all these
things and then what do we do right here
with some chocolate right exactly but
what we're basically saying is this
we're going we understand this is
something that's natural in your body
that you can't help so we put up with
that we understand that and we're very
tolerant of it right now because it's a
natural thing they can't help we got
this natural thing we can't help right
[ __ ] [ __ ] which is wanting to [ __ ]
lots of girls women don't have that they
don't look at every single guy go I want
to [ __ ] them they look at guys you know
they're damaged we're talking about
we're talking about like girls when
they're young when they're young they're
not going I want to [ __ ] seven guys in
my house when I'm older no they're like
I want to marry a guy I want to start a
family I want to have these things
that's what they desire right they later
we're our nature is to want to have sex
with these other girls doctor and just
as we understand the fact that they have
this tough thing that they're going
through with their period do you think
that maybe we should get some
understanding when we're not being
celery look at some stereotypes that
have existed and discuss why they exist
the first woman to talk about is all men
cheat that's a stereotype sudhir really
that's true yes I do I heard all men
cheat really they all lie and I think
they changed
in the closet that's not cheating and
then hold their hand on the way out of
the closet my girlfriend that's why we
lie and they cheat do you think it's bad
or anything kinetic I don't think people
should be together for the whole lose
the genetic jinenji well I think of a
guy of the feeling wants to not know but
don't you feel is a certain amount of
genetic predisposition we do it at our
own even with our own damage we do it
we'll still do it see that's that
vaginal you're insane
listen one day you'll learn how to not
be take your vagina put it over here and
take your take who you are that and put
it over there I can't stand up wait
instead of forcing us to like all of you
when you could be a loser and I just
want to sleep with you but I don't want
the other part that don't make no sense
I'm sorry Patrice you're right
so you need no I thought he could be the
next dr. Phil with that kind of
compassion upstairs just now with Liz
and Amanda and better you know producers
weren't so I'm up there and we're about
to bust bets balls on something good we
gotta write something good and I start
to slam Liz and Amanda were there for
the beginning of the slam I lose them
because they're looking at a shoe in
talking about the shoe he's like you or
your vagina
I want you to know you'll be on your way
to frame that's the whitest couple I've
ever seen in my life what is couple of
you saying it's a criticism where you
are proud to be explodes and the light
in it oh shoot don't say the N word come
on there's still friends see women don't
give us sex to prove that we like you
the longer we wait that means oh he
really likes me men you we want sex from
you because that proves to us that you
like us so if you if you mean the first
date I'm not gonna take you a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] I'm gonna love you yeah I'm gonna
take you out on a retreat you better
wanted the bottom line is this what
happened was the sexual revolution blow
it for women before that have sex you'd
have to get married and what happened
was somehow somebody got them to think
[Applause]
we can undress we can't stop laughing
but I'll tell you what my wife does have
sex she screamed Oh especially when I
walk in on him caught cheating
hey there freckles the clown I'm a
married guy in my mid-30s
I don't want to bore everyone with the
details but I recently got cheated got
caught cheating on my wife with the
25-year old lady the affair went on for
about four months and the truth is I
really started to like this girl after
getting caught in spending a few nights
in a hotel my wife graciously suggests
that we work up with that we work on our
marriage and try to put this mess behind
us we have two small children so all
logic points to me agreeing to get the
help we need and to move on with our
marriage the only problem is that I
can't get this other girl out of my mind
these women are two polar opposites of
each other my wife a professional more
conservative woman and the other girl is
a 25 year old party girl I know what the
clear answer is but I do I snap out of
this and put this other girl out of my
mind all right this is a very simple one
sir first of all your wife is a saint
all right that she's gonna take you back
and I'm not judging you
all right I am a man we've all been
there all right she's a saint that she's
gonna [ __ ] take you back all right so
you got to treat her like that one and
secondly what do you do how do you get
this girl out of your mind
easy you wake up in the morning you walk
into a bathroom you close the door and
you'll rub one out to her and then you
get on with your [ __ ] day all right
go in there close the door rub one out
when you done rubbing one out it's just
gonna hit you
what am i out of my [ __ ] mind listen
how you describe you know these women
they're two polar opposites my wife is a
professional more conservative woman and
the other girl is a 25 year old party
girl why don't you just say it your wife
is the kind of girl you marry and this
other girl is a [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
though it ain't it's not worth it just
[ __ ] just get it out of this I'm
telling you if you're any sort of an
intelligent human being the second you
rub one out you're gonna be thinking I
don't want to call that other girl what
am i a [ __ ] idiot and you're gonna
look at your kids what the hell was I
thinking all right other than that if
you don't you're an idiot all right cuz
this is what's gonna happen sir you're
gonna lose your wife your kids are gonna
hate you you're gonna lose your house
you can end up on a futon in a studio
apartment and that 25 year old party
girl is gonna move on to somebody else
and you're gonna be left there with your
dick in your hand so both scenarios you
end up with your dick in your hand would
you like to do it in a 4-bedroom house
or a [ __ ] studio apartment with empty
Chinese food containers all around as
you cry yourself to sleep wondering what
the [ __ ] happened Jesus we got a we got
a sponsor there Louis a sh Li
madison.com
what's that for that sir you want to
cheat yeah if you're a guy you're
married or a woman and you're married
and you want to cheat you go to
ashleymadison.com and you hook up with
each other oh and you both want but it's
a rib site where there's just where
there's a record well you kind of watch
what you're doing yeah but that's
because you both want to be discreet so
you do that and you [ __ ] each other and
then just really kill you kill yeah
that's not a saying then you killed a
woman a husband gets blamed for it and
then you just run another chick it's a
great website easing of course
ashleymadison.com is a wonderful website
god yeah
times are tough advertising wise oh
don't worry so let's embrace this body
and sound and people against a real
sponsor people really like a website yes
you cheat on your lovely tune
advertising we're not doing an SNL skit
here this no it's you real deal you go
there and there women and men want to
cheat on their logo well and to see the
chicks going Shh shut up you'll never
see lips that are this nice on this
website no they're beautiful women on
there oh hell yeah oh the same say
they're [ __ ] David
sponsor Walker a minute on it let's say
no women of all nationalities that's
right yes black people don't cheat
otherwise not like in every other way
mmm we try best [ __ ] everybody at the
same time hey dude turn up in the
strangest places or cheetah or the dump
the dump seems to be a good place to put
a fella because you fall in love with
the girl you're cheatin on yeah yeah
it's on a now it's not Bill Kurtis to
tell you one will tarnish it was 12:05
p.m. on the day of December 12 when I
know how this is gonna end exactly say
gonna be good let's talk about
ashleymadison.com for a second there's a
service out there little for people that
are unhappily married and instead of
going through a divorce because some
people feel like holy [ __ ] I can't
afford a divorce so they stay married
and they're doing some of that [ __ ]
on the side yeah I get divorce and s in
Madison calm is there to help those
people get the numbers just get divorce
right now fine but you're just not get
any sex but she's taking care of the
house the kids whatever usual
[ __ ] you know percent discrete totally
its discrete so she's not gonna find out
be a man you're gonna hook up with some
chick maybe she's in a marriage a
loveless marriage
don't be a [ __ ] can let her touch the
street everything sex is the perfect one
little little woman at that you need
some sex
Louis I'd Louie makes a good point well
regardless if you leave or not I think
you should go to ask Ashley Madison doc
look I can get laid by calling that
place do it yeah if you're in a shitty
marriage get out of it
a lot of people don't want to they can
what yes that you're a lot stronger a
lot of people Louis yes we you are a lot
stronger than a lot of them not strong
some people can't they have a strong I'm
this in retrospect I couldn't do it let
me tell you if I have used this service
I'd be married today probably you don't
want to thank God I didn't hear this
commercial before 100% secure completely
anonymous and free to join go to
ashleymadison.com
it's absolutely free join now what the
hell find your lovers here at
ashleymadison.com
[Music]